get away christian
another uh breakthrough a player in this
round rue yang yan with a huge victory
against atleast lee rouyang first of all
welcome back to the show what are your
first
feelings after this big victory uh it
feels pretty good because because i
because i choked like a really good
position last round so it feels good to
like you know like win
what was the strategy you were playing
with the white pieces against one of the
toughest competitors in this tournament
and you know alice quite well how did
you approach this game uh i i didn't
like really like prep that much i just
like looked through my lines and you
know i just like yeah just i just like
went with the flow i just wanted to go
with the flow and play the game let's
take a look at the game how did you uh
feel the opening went
were you happy with the outcome uh yeah
and but like after like like in the
middle of the opening i was like pretty
confused like what i was supposed to do
so like i kind of thought for a long
time but i like this like rook f1 f4
idea um i didn't like i didn't want to
like trade the bishops because because
like i'm playing like like pressure
position and
um
yeah
f4 and and this was a moment that kind
of confused us a little bit and here on
the panel
the two guys on the other side of
this board uh we're saying that black is
actually better
how did you assess this end game uh and
the engine was saying that white is
better by the way just to give you uh
an insight but i also felt like black
should be more or less fine how did you
assess it yeah i thought black was fine
but i thought um because like if i could
like push like d4 and e5 or something i
would be okay and her dark squares are
kind of uh weird i guess
and i could pressure f7 pawn
so yeah well you definitely uh had the
more accurate assessment
of at this position because it was
indeed much better for white for that
particular reason the fact that you're
starting to push your central majority
as you did in the game
so
what was the next critical moment in
your opinion uh i don't know maybe
around here yes because like she traded
off my good night but um but i kind of
realized like at first i was like out i
was kind of like you know iffy about
this position but but i kind of realized
that like
um like she can't really do anything
and like i could just like pressure her
and you know like maybe like treat all
the bishops or like d4 and b4 and then
like
uh i don't know like i could like i
could always like push and she has to
like defend it so it's like the f5 is
really
pleasant for you yes yeah
so you feel like you have pretty decent
chances of winning right yeah
and then
when did you feel like the critical
moment came that gave you a winning
point yeah after like rookie a um africa
bishop c4
like maybe like h4 wasn't that good like
i could have done like bishop c4
immediately mm-hmm but like he just like
i just like didn't like i don't know
like i i just like i just like wanted to
like hold the position to like move
forward and
yeah improve the position to the maximum
why not
why not and it did feel like you're
breaking through right now creating
another
king e7 wasn't good i think what else
could she have but did she really have
like anything else to do like d7 maybe
yeah
maybe like b7 but like
i don't know i have like g5 h5 or like
like rook f7 stuff
yeah
but i i feel like rook g7 i feel like
she was gonna try to go like king e7 and
try to hold the position and like rook
ba try to create counter play on the
queen side but this doesn't but like i
kind of saw this h5 idea
so yeah
royang a big victory uh for you it
almost feels like you're so young yet it
feels like you're one of the most
experienced players on this roster
are you going to try to go for a victory
in this event yeah this is the big plan
guys any questions
no our congratulations uh just that you
played
with such control and you kept
um alice essentially out of the game we
thought this was a very well played game
keep it up
keep your success going well done